s'il n'y a pas grand monde dans les rues
des herbiers ce soir c'est normal et oui
le ssh affronte actuellement en 32e de
finale de la coupe de france la dh de
compiègne même s'il affiche n'est pas un
événement et la tire tout de même les
foules en milieu de semaine 1500 tickets
avaient déjà été vendus bref dans cette
commune de 15 mille habitants le public
est plutôt assidus mais en championnat
nathan des cinq à six cents personnes
contenu qu'on avait déjà 3 400 l'an
dernier on espérer en gagner
quelques-uns comptable est donc sur cinq
avec un secret espoir de 600 personnes
réunies 100 à 1000 personnes à tous les
matchs mais 1200 pour shaun et c'est
bien au delà nos espérances et avec les
performances en coupe de france
l'engouement est plus fort que jamais
nous y retournerons de finale n'ont
jamais aussi loin
maintenant j'ai pas bien qu'en voyant
dans 16e on sait jamais on a on a tout
pour bien faire le public on joue chez
nous et et puis et puis le public est
tout le monde est là pour pousser tout
le monde
l'équipe d'éric bourges est donc très
attendu par les supporters favorite sur
le papier elle pourrait se créer une
occasion unique de poursuivre l'aventuré
concernant l'équipe et votre passion
particulière en ce retard comme
d'habitude
sachant que le tirage nous a donné un
adversaire hiérarchiquement inférieur
donc nous a donné et possibilité
d'accéder en seizièmes donc c'est vrai
que ça ajoute un petit peu de pression
quand même sur sur le groupe
entraîneur joueur côté tribunes on n'a
pas la pression et on pense déjà à la
suite
après un teckel ou alors marseille
rencontré une première division voilà
les voeux des supporters pour le tirage
en cas de victoire
[Musique]